>> All right, welcome Cynthia to
Microsoft Research
as part of your,
the talk that you're going
to give in the next hour.
So, a pleasure to have you here.
>> Thank you.
>> To just get started
with, I'd love to,
you know, what got you
started in the whole
area of robotics, especially
in the social robotics.
>> Yeah.
>> What were the biggest
motivations and inspirations?
Tell us about your initial part
of your journey.
>> Yeah, so I think,
looking back, I can tell
a very linear story.
When you're living life,
it's really not that way.
I mean, you go on
various branches of
your life's path and you
end up where you end up,
which has been
an incredible journey.
But for me, I mean, I do
think it really started,
I was 10 and the first
Star Wars movie came out.
I think today,
kids today don't understand
what a phenomenon that was.
It's like, I remember sitting
in the theater and the Imperial
whatever galactic star
or whatever
was going overhead, and
the seats were vibrating.
It was just, like,
this awe-inspiring experience
from the very beginning and then,
these droids came on the screen
and I just fell in
love with them.
I think it's because they
weren't just robots,
like useful robots,
but it was really because
they were full-fledged
characters.
They had rich personalities.
They had relationships
not only with each
other, but with
the main human characters,
and they really cared
about one another.
I thought that emotional
connection really stuck with me,
and I think the whole world
fell in love with
those robots for a reason.
So fast forward,
I ended up doing
my graduate work at
the MIT Artificial Intelligence
Lab, before it was CSAIL,
where Professor Rod
Brooks was my adviser and
he's recognized as the father
of autonomous robots.
I remember when I was admitted
as a graduate student
and looking at
the various schools and
deciding where I should go,
and I walked into
Rod Brooks' lab,
which was then called
the Mobile Robotics Group.
I saw all these little
insect inspired robots,
and a lot of the work that was
around biological
inspiration intelligence.
I remember just
thinking, "Oh, my God!
If those robots and Star Wars
are ever going to really
become a reality,
it's going to star in
a lab just like this.
In fact, maybe this lab."
And I'm like, "I
have to be here."
So that was really it.
It was the promise of robots
as artificial creatures,
back then, very
inspired by insects,
But then you could imagine
the evolution of that.
We thought, we would
go from insects,
to like reptiles to like I
don't know mammals or whatever
then eventually maybe,
eventually maybe
you get to people.
But I remember when Rod
went on sabbatical,
he did this world tour.
He came back and he's
like, "We're doing
humanoids." We're like, "What?"
It's like we just got done
doing insects, we're
doing humanoids.
It's because he spent time
as part of that in Japan,
and he had seen all of
this humanoid work.
You know back then,
the reason why
humanoid robotics was
so important in Japan
was just they were
already grappling
with this profound shift, right,
where the ratio of
working-age people
to retired-age persons
was going to hit
their country harder than
many other countries.
They were already thinking
about robots as a way
of helping to bridge that gap.
But humanoid was,
because so much of
our human engineered space,
was about this morphology,
walking around, tools,
everything was built
for this morphology.
So that's why you
wanted humanoids.
I remember the day
that I was still a
graduate student, NASA
landed robots on Mars.
I remember thinking,
because then,
the value proposition of autonomy
was about the dull, dirty, and
dangerous far from people, right?
That was why you did
autonomous robots.
I remember thinking to myself,
"All right, here we are. We
send robots into the oceans,
we send them into
volcanoes, and now, we
even land them on Mars.
Why aren't they in
our living rooms?"
It was that moment that
I'm like, "It's because
designing a machine
and intelligence
that can deal with
the inanimate world,
navigating around rocks on Mars
is fundamentally different than
designing an intelligent
machine that has
to interact with entities,
whose behavior is governed
by having a mind."
That was totally different.
Nobody was really working on
that problem of robots
for the rest of us.
It was always autonomous robots
as tools for professionals.
Nobody was really thinking about
autonomous robots in
people's homes, where
young children to seniors and
everyone in between would
be able to interact and get
value from this kind
of technology.
So that was the moment,
and I remember I marched
into poor Rod's office
and I'm like,
"I have to change it, everything.
I [inaudible] my PhD,
I'm changing it.
I'm doing social human
robot interaction."
That's when I started
building Kismet,
and he, I mean to
Rod's credit, he was, like,
"That's an important
problem. Go do it."
Now, you might have thought he
might have been all freaked out
having a student say, "I
have to change everything,"
but he was always so supportive.
I mean, I think one of
his greatest strengths,
he was always a visionary.
Yeah. You could tell when
there was a problem that
was really worth pursuing.
So anyway, I'm very fortunate
to have been a student of
Rod Brooks because he gave me
the freedom to do something
crazy like Kismet,
which was around
the social emotional
face-to-face interaction
with robots.
That was considered kind
of crazy at the time.
>> Yeah. Very inspiring.
I mean, having some time
spent at MIT as well, I've
realized that sometimes you
have these ideas,
which might feel
so out of the box or difficult.
So for instance,
when we think about
these robots that would
be around inanimate
objects like spiders,
around rocks.
If you think about it, we
know the laws of motion,
the laws of physics for
almost 300 years now.
Even when we know those laws,
building something
is more difficult.
Now, you're getting into
the realm of social robotics,
where we don't have
these laws well-defined.
We are still studying it.
Don't think it was kind of
crazy, and what do you think,
given the difficulty
of this challenge,
what hope do we have
in accomplishing
something like that in
the next five or ten years?
What are your thoughts on this?
>> Yeah. So I think, I mean,
certainly as a graduate student,
what we had known already
from building these
autonomous robots was that
people had a very
powerful tendency
to want to anthropomorphize
them, right?
They didn't only
think about them as
kind of useful tools.
I mean they really, applied what
we would call our kind
of social thinking,
theory of other minds
and so forth, to try
to reason about and make sense
of the robots' behavior.
So, one of the key
starting hypotheses was if this
is how the human mind
naturally is trying to make
sense of this
autonomous-behaving entity,
then what we need to
do is understand that
and designed to
support the way that
people want to think about and
understand and collaborate
with these technologies.
So, it was always a very
human-centered,
human-driven process.
The other thing, of
course, is that I
recognize that trying to model
adult human-human
interaction was like,
that's crazy because we
are the most socially,
emotionally sophisticated
species on the planet.
So the thought was,
"What is the simplest
social other that I could
model that adults would still
treat as a social entity?"
So, a lot of that work with
Kismet was really inspired by
social development of
infant-caregiver interactions.
It's so much of the developmental
psychology is about.
The critical roles that
we, as the caring,
nurturing adults, play
in treating the infant,
treating the baby as
though he or she is fully
socially intelligent and
capable because it's
those interactions that are
needed in order for the child
to learn how to be calm.
So you treat as though,
so they learn to be calm.
So, that was the paradigm
behind Kismet.
So, it was all about
this very first
face-to-face social
emotional work,
where our communication starts.
It grows and develops over time.
So that's kind of how I
started, just appreciating.
You got to start in
the primordial aspect of this,
but understanding and learning
so much and just not about
emotion and social processes and
theory of other mind
processes on a machine.
I mean, that's like
whole new areas of AI now,
but also starting to appreciate
the human side of
that partnership.
So in reading that literature,
I contrast it so much today,
where so many of the AIs
we interact with,
they feel very transactional,
they feel very much
like playing chess.
I say something,
machine responds.
Communication is not like that.
Human communication
is nothing like that.
It's a dance. Often and a
lot of this literature,
they talk about
the mother-infant dance,
and it's because the way we
communicate and collaborate is
so dynamic and interwoven
and mutually regulating.
That's what we do
in order to really
coordinate states of
mind and behavior.
It's obvious to me at
the time that that was one of
the biggest challenges
of creating
this kind of socially
collaborative technology.
It was getting the nuances
of that dance right,
and it's richly non-verbal
in addition to being verbal,
in addition to just inferring
this invisible states of mind,
beliefs, intense desires from
watching human behavior.
I mean, again, so I think
one of the examples
is that because
we as humans do it
so effortlessly,
we assume it's easier
than it really is.
I think it's one of the
most sophisticated,
hardest AI challenges facing
us is understanding how to create
these robots or intelligent
machines that can actually
really collaborate
with us as others.
So sophisticated and
complex and nuanced.
>> Yeah. Actually, it blows
my mind when I think about
the complexities
when I'm interacting
with my two-year-old
or five-year-old.
How sophisticated, how adaptive
they are and how
quickly they learn,
and you have to almost keep
at phase as they are growing.
If you look at the landscape of
the recent advances in
machine learning and AI,
you'll see that many
of these successes
are data heavy, deep
machine learning,
hundreds and millions
of data points,
and trials, and images,
and sound recordings.
Given the complexity of
the problem that you
just described, I mean,
can you comment on is data
the way to go there, or are
there other mechanisms that
we should think about that
goes beyond the realm of just
collecting or doing some kind
of reinforcement learning,
for instance?
>> Sure. I mean, I think
the punch line is way more.
So, even, again, when I
started reading and starting
a lot of the infant psychology,
it was very apparent
that even despite all of
our evolutionary advantages
and endowments,
when we are born into the world,
there's a lot of
machinery up there,
it's not just data.
It's a lot of machinery,
a lot of structure that
when we gain the
experience from the world,
that's what allows us to actually
learn the right kinds of things.
So, it's got to be a combination
of the right cognitive,
emotional, social kind of
mechanisms married
with the experience.
That is what really
makes this happen.
Of course, we also know
that in tragic situations
where infants don't receive
enough social interaction,
they become irrevocably,
severely retarded.
So even again for ourselves,
if we don't get
the right interaction
with others in the social world,
we need the kind of scaffolding
of empathetic other to help
us learn on the right path.
So, I think that was just
again very eye-opening for me
and just very cognizant as
we try to create these AI.
So, deep learning, of course, has
been hugely successful
and there's still a lot,
I guess, a lot of runway
for deep learning.
But it is about
large data sets and
pre-labeled data sets, which is
very labor intensive to create.
There is a lot of data
that doesn't readily
exist right now.
So when you talk about this
interpersonal, mutual,
regulated dynamics
of interaction,
that has to be learned
from experience.
There may be ways of
simulating that to get
a bootstrap up on that,
but human behavior, again, is
so rich and nuanced and averse.
You still, I think, you're
going to need real interaction
in order to learn the right kinds
of behaviors and mechanisms.
So, I do think
reinforcement learning
is going to be important.
I think it's clear
that we can also make
these inferences.
So, the theory of other minds
sorts of challenges.
I mean, it's ways of even
simulating as a way of
reasoning and predicting,
our other sets of
mechanisms that we use.
Empathy, the ability to learn
by watching others,
taking their perspective,
using their experience as
a surrogate for
your own experience as
social learning is
a whole other suite
of many different kinds of
social learning that we use.
So, again, I think we have
so many ways of
understanding the world and
so many ways of learning from
experience that it's going
to be an orchestra
of these kinds of methods to
really get to the AI that
we associate with being
like the socially,
emotionally, intelligent
creature that
we can collaborate with.
So, we're just
scratching the surface.
Just scratching the surface.
>> Yeah, definitely. In fact,
it reminds me of when you were
doing the work on Kismet,
you had mentioned that
one of the reasons
that Kismet doesn't talk,
because it's depicting
the state of the technology.
It's still in infancy,
so it's appropriate for us to
basically talk to an infant.
It's been almost 20
years since that worked.
What's your sense of
one of the things that
have evolved? Are we
still at the state of infancy,
or has the technology matured?
What's your take on that?
>> So, I think
the technology has advanced,
of course, a great deal,
and yet, it still has
a long way to go.
So, when we started with Kismet,
it was very, very difficult
to be able to have
robust ASR or automatic
speech recognition.
The machine vision
was very primordial.
I think one of
the most exciting things
that's happened more recently
is just the performance and
affordability of
those core technologies,
have advanced to the state,
although they're
far from perfect,
they're interesting
enough that you can
start to create services,
products, whatever
you want to call it,
that actually are
interesting to people.
They can certainly
get a lot better,
a lot more sophisticated,
but at least you can start to
build real systems that are
actually able to provide
value in the world.
In many ways, by doing that,
just become painstakingly clear
also about the opportunity
and the challenge that still
lies ahead to really
have these systems meet
our visions and our aspirations
for what they'll be able
to be in our lives.
But just the ability to build
these systems in a
way that you can
actually put them in the world
is hugely important.
Even from a research standpoint,
hugely important because
until these systems
are in real environments
where real people
interacting with them,
you don't really know
what the phenomenon
even is that you're trying
to develop for and understand.
So, that's been tremendous
and fairly recent.
Even right now, I
would say, whatever,
43 million Newton smart
speakers in people's homes now,
people are living with AI in
a way they never did before,
and who is interacting with
AI is fundamentally different.
It used to be just
like people like us.
Now, it's young children
and seniors and
everyone in-between,
and we know very little
about how to design for
the diversity of needs and
opportunities of
such wide demographics.
We still don't understand what
this long-term relationship
is going to be.
We build these very
transactional systems,
but by and large.
But I think the next level
is kind of the Star Wars dream,
robot sidekick,
helpful companion.
Not just a digital assistant,
but a helpful companion
that is with you
and works with you
towards your goals
and really is your collaborator.
That's still, I think,
where this is going.
To me, that's like
a whole other layer
beyond where we are right now.
>> Yeah. You're absolutely right.
So, I've been following
your work over
the course of the time.
One thing I've realized is that
there is little bit of emphasis
on building robots of
the form such that you
can interact with them.
For instance, they'll have eyes,
they'll have some kind
of capability
of making some kind of sound,
expressions, et cetera.
You contrast that to something
like smart speakers
that you talked about.
What role do you think such,
for the lack of a better word,
I'm using the word of
anthro and to more
feisty, for instance,
basically, is important in
establishing social
rapport with humans?
>> Absolutely. Yeah, so I think
the decades of science that's
been done in this field,
there's been so many
rigorous, randomized,
controlled trials,
literally comparing
a physically embodied robot with
various cues and affordances
to graphical agents on a screen,
to voice only agents,
and now more recently,
to talking speakers.
I think the data
and the evidence is
pretty clear that
the co-physical,
co-presence, social
emotional embodiment of
the technology actually makes
a significant difference in
how people engage with it.
Again, it's just
speaking to the fact
that we have evolved
specialized neural
structures to do
the social thinking and
inference with another that
when you create a technology
that gives us those hooks,
our minds engage with it in
a much richer, deeper way.
So, if you can have
that depth of engagement,
when people can invest more of
themselves in
the multiple ways we
have of understanding and
reasoning and engaging
with something,
not just cognitive but the
social and emotional and
even the physical as well,
the more successful often
we actually are because
we're just able to put
more of ourselves into
that interaction.
I think that's one
of the key, I think,
consistent insights from a lot
of the work that's been done.
Now, how human is
another question, right?
So, I think this is
an important point
because there's been kind of
this assumption that the
more plug compatible
human, the better.
I actually don't think that's
panned out in the data.
I think there is
a different kind of
relationship that people
can have with an other,
that's a non-human other.
So, you think about
companion animals, right?
We can have meaningful,
beneficial relationships
with non-human entities.
In fact, one of the most
profound things, I think,
about companion animals
is the fact that you can
have this relationship that you
feel is non-judgmental and
it's just a different kind of
social, emotional support.
So, that's just to say that
you can design a robot,
a machine that does not
have to be human-like,
to have actually
a really important kind
of interaction relationship that
provides tremendous value
to the person.
So, we intentionally design
our robots to be anthropomorphic,
to be familiar enough
that it can tap into
the social thinking processes
of the way that our brains
are wired to work without
trying to overstep and being too
human because it actually
starts to set up
a whole host of
expectations that,
first of all, I think,
we would not be able to uphold.
Secondly, from
a philosophical standpoint,
I feel like we've
got a lot of people,
why do we want to make
robots look like people?
It's like people are people.
The intriguing design
challenge here
is how to create
a technology that
complements and dovetails and
augments who we are
and how we do well.
As opposed to trying to more-
>> -would make us.
>> -of what we are,
right? So, for me,
that's a philosophical stance.
But I've definitely
been finding that in
creating non-human
anthropomorphic like robots
has opened up huge opportunities
for a different kind
of relationship,
a far more humanistic experience
and relationship with technology
that actually empowers people.
So, again, I think it's
one thing to use a useful tool,
it's another thing
to interact with
an empathetic supportive other.
Different ways we
engage the world are
unlocked when we engage
with an empathetic
support of others.
So, when you look at things
like around behavior change
or learning something new
or aging with independence,
these are all domains where
the social and
emotional support are
critical for our well-being,
for our ability to flourish.
We need to be able to
extend the kind of
services and support
that people provide,
either as family members
or as professionals.
You may be able to get
world-class kind of
support and intervention
in the institution,
but what's missing
now is we can't bring
that same quality of
care to the home.
So, when you think
about the opportunity
of scalable, affordable,
high-quality,
personalized services and
support in the home,
that's hugely empowering.
I would love to have
a personal tutor for
my son living with us
and teach him Mandarin.
I can't afford that, right?
But with the right kind
of AI, that's possible.
I think we just live in
a time where people just,
we need help in
order to just to be able to
fulfill our opportunity,
to open up opportunity.
To me, that's one of
the biggest promises
of this technology.
It's really supporting people
to have the opportunity to
become who we aspire to be.
>> Yeah.
>> I think the democratization of
that kind of services
and support is going
to be critical, and
making that accessible
to everyone to have
an AI- for AI,
I think, to truly
fulfill its potential.
>> Yeah.
>> It needs to be able to
truly benefit everyone.
As part of that, I feel it's
not only enough that we try to
design this kind of
humanistic AI with that in mind,
but also we need to
empower children,
people of all ages to understand
this technology, right?
So, I'm a big advocate now of
K12 AI education because children
now are not just digital natives,
they're AI natives, right?
They're growing up
now, where they've
always been able to talk
to intelligent machines.
People don't understand
enough of what
this technology is. They
need to understand that.
They need to grow up
feeling empowered
that they can create with it.
So, I think this is
also really important.
So, if only a small subset of
a population is knowledgeable
enough to create solutions-
>> Yeah.
>> -by definition,
it's only going to
serve a narrow part of
the population and
that's going to
exacerbate any divide,
not close it.
So, I think a lot about
the democratization
of AI on how you empower many,
many more people to
create solutions of
personal significance
through this technology.
>> Yeah. When you talk
about AI fulfilling
this ambitious goal,
one of the things that occurs
to me is that we are asking
this technology to actually
do many things well together.
It's being about, say,
a speech recognition, or
recognize social cues, or take
actions, or help us drive
on the streets safely,
et cetera, et cetera.
But as a species we excel at
engineering where there was
very well-defined goal.
For instance, let's build cars,
let's build bridges,
let's build airplanes,
but now we talk
multi technology that
needs to do many things well.
So, from a design standpoint,
how do you think about
building such technologies?
Are the certain principles
in your world that you'd
have found out that
we should be aware of and we
should think about those?
>> Yeah. So, I would definitely,
in the nature of my work.
So, the core of my work
is really about
how do you create the
human-machine partnership, right?
That, I think, the core
fundamentals that cut across
any sort of purpose or
problem to be solved,
is what nature of
intelligence and capability
the machine need to have
to support this
human partnership.
There's a lot we can learn
from psychology around
the role of these
non-verbal cues, to how you
infer goals and
intense and desires,
and how you get
that from language,
all of these kind of, again,
the social and emotional
intelligence of the machine.
That is a very rich,
relatively very under
explored area of AI,
but I think that's the foundation
that cuts across all of it.
If you want to create
collaborative technologies
that empower people.
Then, you get down to
the specific purposes, right?
There may be multiple purposes,
but then there's
a whole other host
of design decisions you may
make depending on how focused
or broad that needs to be.
So, there's, I think, a core set
of social emotional
intelligence challenges that,
again, we're still in
our infancy of understanding.
Then, there's understanding
how that intersects with
the affordances of the utility
and function that, which would
have influence the nature,
the embodiment and the sensors,
and the other kind of
knowledge in machine
learning algorithm that
would go into creating that.
But I think, when we
were graduate students,
I think it may still be the case.
There was this bias that
system integration
wasn't interested,
that building these systems,
that wasn't research, that
was just engineering.
That the science was
something different, right?
I think now, maybe we're
starting to deeply
understand that
building the whole
brain-body system
is actually really hard research.
Really, really hard research.
We've got to start thinking about
the integration of all of
these things, rather
than thinking
we can go deep and narrow,
went to core
capacities and think,
"You just stick it
together, and that's all."
That's, like, no. No, no, no, no.
That's not the case. Then, you
have to put it in the world,
and now you see how
people engage with
it and then there's
a whole other host of learners
that thinks you've
got to figure out.
So, I mean, we live
in interesting times.
>> Yeah. No. You know,
the whole area of robotics'
social and emotional robots,
as you said, it's
incredibly difficult
enduring challenge.
So, one final parting question,
one final question that I
wanted to ask you is that,
for someone who aspires
to be in this field,
who wants to work with robotics,
who wants to work about,
think about the society
and affect of systems,
and things like those.
The barrier to entry right
now is quite high, right?
In the spirit of
democratizing, for instance,
AI and machine learning
to the world,
how an aspiring student
should think about?
Do you have any advices,
any word of advice for them?
>> Yeah. I think-
So, that's also why I'm
so passionate about
even pre-K12 AI education
because I want to
make these experiences
accessible for many,
many more kids much earlier on.
I think, right now,
based on when we were
kids, we had Lego, right?
Now, there is Mindstorms
and there's Scratch,
and there's all these other kinds
of ways that kids can
actually get into
coding and programming
and interacting with
the technology,
which is phenomenal.
We need to bring it into schools.
That needs to come into our
K-12 formal education process.
There's movement to try to
bring computer science,
and with that I think we want
to bring in AI education.
I just think that's
important just to make
the opportunity
available to people.
There are a lot of
after-school activities.
There are a number of
products on the market.
There's a lot of things
you can do online.
I think the good news
is there's way
that you can start to get
your hands dirty with
this kind of stuff.
What we really want
to do is just make
that richer and more
empowering, I think,
for kids to be able
to apply that,
honestly at all ages,
to things that matter to
them because I think
that's when you really
start to develop empathy and you
start to appreciate that creating
solutions is not just this field
or that field or the other,
but it's how they
all come together,
and we're both from
the media lab.
So, we're already commerce
of multi-disciplinary thinking.
But to build real things
that will impact
real people's lives,
the insights and the ways of
understanding across
these sub-disciplines,
they have to come together.
That's when you really come
up with the solutions.
I think that makes sense.
But building that empathy
and the ability to
have those conversations and
the appreciation of these
different ways of thinking and
understanding is also
really important.
>> Yeah. Great. Thank
you for the good time.
I enjoyed the conversation.
>> Yeah. Thank you.